frank van der linde filed a court case
in amsterdam against police to find out
why europol is spying on him the dutch
activist says the worst he did was break
a window during a protest for homeless
people while police in the netherlands
admitted vandalinda is no danger to
society he has yet to find out what
europol knows about him they don't have
grip on the data and if they don't have
grip on the data and they spread it all
around the world
this is super dangerous what is the
danger
the danger is getting arrested and
ending up in in in a police custody or
worse uh in a certain country because
they don't like political activist or
left-wing political activists in my case
europol obtained personal data of
thousands of citizens after french
police hacked into an encrypted phone
messaging service as a result dutch
french german and british police
arrested hundreds of suspected criminals
in 2020 in the so-called anchor chat
case the most remarkable find was a
container equipped to torture people
lawyers are questioning the legality of
the operation
you see a wave of court cases now in the
netherlands uk france spain finland and
germany everyone is fighting this but so
far clarity has not been given this is
quite unique because angkor chat is one
of the biggest hacks ever done by the
police and they should clarify if it was
done legally the european data
protection supervisor has compared
europol's practices with those at the
american spy agency as revealed by
whistleblower edward snowden in 2013. so
you cannot collect the data
just in case it will be
necessary it will be useful in the
future you should know from the very
beginning
what the data is thought for this is the
difference between the european approach
and the approach in some other parts of
the world
where it is acceptable
that the data is stored in case it will
be useful in the future europol declined
to comment on camera but in a written
response the agency says that the six
months time limit for data storage is
not enough and that it is assessing how
the supervisor's decision to destroy the
data will affect the security of eu
citizens while most europeans won't
complain about data storage for criminal
networks there is concern about the
millions of innocent people who are
being monitored
the european commission is discussing if
legislation to allow europol's mass data
storage should be adopted i'm actually
quite surprised that what happened at
that time with nsa
everybody was was speaking out very
clearly in the eu and now the eu's are
doing it themselves and there is not so
much outcry yet van der linde is calling
on other europeans to go to court to
demand access to the files stored about
them but he warns it could take many
years before they'll receive answers
stop fasting al jazeera amsterdam